let's get right into that story in his
canter rips disgusting lebron's
uh james over nike connection this is a
washington examiner story he continued
his war against nike on thursday saying
sparring no words while ripping into
lebron james cantor who has previously
accused nike of telling a total lie
about china's alleged use of slave labor
to produce its products aimed this round
at nike's biggest star money over morals
for the king the celtics center tweeted
sad and disgusting how these athletes
pretend they care about social justice
they really do shut up and dribble when
big boss says so do you educate yourself
did you educate yourself about the slave
labor and made your shoes
or is that not part of your research
james refused to offer his own thoughts
about china's political policies instead
claiming he had to conduct more research
so i mean they're going back and forth
here and his cantor's not going to slow
down but lebron what he said in the
interview he says
hey he walked through the hallway he
could have stopped and talked to me but
he didn't do anything he's trying to
make his name like he's trying to say
like he's trying to make his name off me
so hey you had the opportunity to face
me and you didn't which by the way i
agree with lebron
why don't you go deal with them directly
if you did walk into the hallway with
them now if lebron's lying which i don't
think he is
he's trying to build himself up ns is
going to come back because i never walk
past this guy okay but if enes now comes
out and says hey i'm willing to do a
live with you let's talk about it if
venice says let's have a meeting and
talk about this now if he wants to kind
of come back at it but
yeah i mean he's right because look what
happened lebron tweeted about kyle
rittenhouse just a couple weeks ago and
he got destroyed for it last week or a
week and a half ago sure but a guy comes
in and drives through a community in
wisconsin kills five people uh
hospitalizes 40 people where is a story
about that what's worse of a story it's
a horrible story horrible story kids
this is like what are you doing
well you you
have you watched a video of course
did you see the car plummeting or like
going over bodies and it's bumping up
and down i'm surprised the kids even got
up because some of them got up like he
just got ran over and he was out on on
uh bail bail thousand dollar bail for he
was running from a domestic dispute he
tried to run his wife over earlier in
the morning like his pregnant or his
pregnant girlfriend he tried to run her
over with this car earlier
we're kind of all over the place in this
story but you know how we talked about
athletes have to invent them reinvent
themselves have to have a second act
clearly innes cantor is
positioning himself for something bigger
than basketball when his career is said
and done now he's sort of more of a
backup he's the backup center on the
celtics now he's been on five teams in
as many years this is not new though i
don't think no exactly he went after
erdogan he went back to one it started
with afraid of exactly not afraid of
erdogan you're not afraid of lebron
james and he can't go back to turkey
they've revoked his visa or his passport
he can't go back there he's been he's
been talking about free tibet he's
obviously
calling out the uyghurs that is going on
in china yeah this is something that
he's doing consistently and he looks at
lebron and he's got
on the court and off the court beef with
lebron they've had some issues um but
the nba needs someone like
um innis cantor to sort of
be the thorn in people's side lebron's
getting challenged if you have to i mean
lebron's had a rough week they came back
after being out for a month
injury now this insult he got he got
suspended how much he got suspended for
again you know how much money he's
losing for that one game as a stuart
yeah isaiah stewart he's losing um what
does it say here probably 500 grand or
something yeah like 300 grand for for
the one game the other guy who has never
even heard his name before he's losing
uh 45 grand out two games
um lebron's had a rough week but i hope
he can recover
yeah i think he's gonna be i think he's
gonna be all right
for facing the league to be that way uh
oh this is the thing right now like do
you expect anything here's but uh i do
actually look a little bit deeper than
you know
who
skip
shannon shannon sharp says on on skip
and shannon that lebron can't ever come
out and say he's friends with louis
farrakhan all right he he's reading
malcolm x he's reading not that this is
bad this is good stuff to read but he he
uses nation of islam
language when he talks he talks about i
stand up for my people
the there's a there's this weird la vibe
where there's this this nouveau
kind of um
like nationalism that's coming out where
this type of rhetoric becomes incredibly
incredibly
familiar to people that that have heard
this before i think and this is just
pure speculation but this is a podcast
and i can speculate i think that there
are some influences that are that are
pretty extreme that have found their way
into lebron's life i think that there's
a lot of influences especially within
the wealthy black community right now
that are
nation of islam slash marxist
in nature and it's becoming this this
this um cultural
epicenter where they've got these like
rich attractive charismatic cultural
icons within the black community
specifically and that's where there's
going to trickle down they're going to
divulge that the marxist and the
nationalist rhetoric and it's you're
hearing it more and more and if you know
what you're listening for it's pretty
obvious so i don't know i think for
someone like ennis cantor here's some
something like that he's a pretty
well-read guy and he's like this this is
this is [ __ ] this guy's full of it
this this guy's spewing nonsense and he
wants to take him to the task about it
well as i always tell you gerard there's
you got you got globalists
and you got you got nationalists
federalists over here and uh you got to
pick a side good job so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you